c'est la première fois qu'on a un iPhone
qui se plie qui est fonctionnel on a
vraiment un iPhone qui se plie je vais
tout vous expliquer vous allez
comprendre d'où vient cet iPhone qui se
plie qu'est-ce qu'il nous raconte ou
est-ce qu'on va aller avec est-ce que
enfin les iPhone pliant pliable arrive
oui ou non est-ce que vous allez pouvoir
l'acheter est-ce que ça va être
intéressant qu'est-ce qui va se passer
on va tout regarder vous allez voir
c'est super intéressant et regarder bien
jusqu'au bout parce que je trouve une
fois de plus que ce sujet est super
passionnant et on va pas être au bout de
nos surprises
les smartphones pliants existent c'est
pas une nouveauté j'enfonce des portes
ouvertes vous le savez on a plein de
produits qui arrivent en France en tout
cas aujourd'hui on a le Samsung Galaxy Z
fold cette fold 4 notamment vous savez
c'est on prend on l'ouvre comme un
espèce de bouquin et ça fait une espèce
de grande tablette on augmente
l'affichage on a un contrario à notre
format qui est territoire un peu de ce
qu'on pouvait retrouver chez Motorola
avant avec le smartphone avec clapet
c'est l'idée du Samsung Galaxy Z flip
c'est-à-dire on a un grand smartphone on
le pli on réduit l'encombrement il y en
a un format de poche ça c'est très cool
et vous avez également d'autres formats
enroulable ou l'écran voilà bon c'est
les écrans amovibles en France on a ces
deux produits qui se vendent on a
également le Motorola riser vous pouvez
venir aussi acheter d'ailleurs je vous
en ai déjà parlé également dans une
précédente vidéo et je vous invite à
venir jeter un œil dessus mais il y a
plein de produits qui vont arriver et
notamment l'année prochaine le Honor
Magic vs je vous en ai parlé je voulais
montrer il y a quelques jours également
à lester un coup d'oeil à ma vidéo et il
y a plein d'autres constructeurs qui
sont en train de se développer dessus
Xiaomi avec son mix fold 2 je l'ai pris
en main je vous ai fait une vidéo
également il y a eu plein de vidéos ça
fait trop cool allez c'était un coup
d'œil sur ma chaîne il y a la version de
oppo il y a la version de vivo bref il y
en a énormément et c'est super
intéressant donc il me paraîtrait
logique que à un moment ou un autre
Apple arrive avec un smartphone qui se
plie c'est normal le marché est là le
marché existe alors il est pas
extrêmement développé je pense que c'est
pour cette raison que aujourd'hui Apple
n'est pas encore dessus prends le temps
de que vraiment ça devienne un marché un
peu plus de masse pour pouvoir les
commercialiser parce qu'en terme de
recherche et développement ça coûte une
blinde ça coûte très cher pour autant
aujourd'hui Samsung est le seul
réellement avant de rentrer en France
même s'il y a Huawei je n'ai pas de
Huawei mais il y a également Huawei qui
est là je vous ai montré aussi un proto
de Tessel en début d'année mais qui
arrivera pas donc voilà donc aujourd'hui
Samsung ce gavent avec ces Samsung
Galaxy Z flip qui sont les seuls
réellement à pouvoir vendre ses produits
le Z fold est très cool mais le Z folle
ça a un produit qui a un peu peu
différent et qui se vend un peu moins
qui est plus cher qui est plus niché
mais sur Netflix vont bien je
m'attendrai donc à voir arriver un
iPhone sous forme de Samsung Galaxy Z
flip un iPhone flip un iPhone fold je ne
sais pas un iPhone qui se plie c'est une
certitude mais aujourd'hui je vous parle
de l'iPhone V l'iPhone V c'est le tout
premier iPhone pliant au monde il est
fonctionnel c'est iOS c'est des
composants d'un iPhone et pour autant
c'est pas Apple qui l'a créé c'est un
ingénieur chinois qui l'a publié sur sa
chaîne Youtube alors je vais vous lancer
les vidéos vous allez voir il y a deux
vidéos une première vidéo où il vous
montre un peu le concept on voit un peu
à quoi ça ressemble et la deuxième qui
est beaucoup plus long on va pas la
regarder en entier rassurez-vous mais je
vous mets le lien de sa chaîne en bas
dans la description allez jeter un œil
parce que c'est vachement passionnant
c'est une vidéo qui est en chinois alors
je sais pas si vous parlez mandarin ce
qui n'est pas mon cas moi mais par
contre elle est sous-titrée en anglais
donc si vous parlez anglais vous pouvez
avoir un petit peu de chance là-dessus
et ça c'est cool donc regardez je vous
montre déjà la toute première vidéo on
voit hop la plat regarder l'iPhone c'est
vraiment l'iPhone qui est fonctionnel
comme ça donc hop alors il vous montre
un peu la puce à 16 il est donc quand
cet iPhone s'il arrive ce sera pas la
puce à 16 sera une autre puce plus tard
probablement dans plusieurs années
probablement donc après leur truc alors
regardez ça c'est super intéressant
parce que oui c'est très grand encoche
si vous avez suivi depuis euh l'iPhone
13 pro et bien sur l'iPhone 13 et iPhone
13 mini vous aviez encore cette très
grande encoche là comme on l'avait
appartient de l'iPhone X mais à partir
de l'iPhone 13 pro et 13 pro max
l'encoche avait un petit peu réduite
c'est intéressant c'est un peu plus
léger alors on a vu que l'iPhone 14 pro
qui a eu le Dynamic Island est encore
une nouvelle histoire donc si on voit
cette grande encoche là et bien c'est
qu'ils sont basés pour venir construire
leur modèle sur un iPhone 10 tout
simplement donc on passe un peu le truc
ok la 5G il est évident qu'on aura un
modem à l'intérieur c'est hallucil c'est
une marque déposée de Apple une caméra
de selfie de 12 mégapixels on s'en doute
bien évidemment que le système de caméra
à l'arrière et voilà le smartphone qui
se plie et qui se déplie alors je vais
vous montrer la vidéo qui est plus
longue et qui est super intéressante à
venir regarder on va pas se regarder en
entier mais on va prendre des moments un
peu fort pour essayer de comprendre
comment ils ont conçu ce smartphone et
qu'est-ce que ça raconte et à quoi
pourrait ressembler peut-être si c'est
ce format qui est sélectionné par Apple
à quoi pourrait ressembler l'iPhone
pliant donc en fait ce qu'ils ont fait
c'est qu'ils sont venus décortiquer
récupérer l'écran d'un iPhone 10 alors
il y a plusieurs couches au niveau de
l'écran mais sont venus récupérer la
partie effectivement pliante on se parle
ici d'un écran OLED pour qu'il puisse se
plier parce que du LCD globalement ça
fonctionnerait pas vous voyez on le voit
bien là petit écran OLED donc alors ils
ont fait plusieurs tentatives vous allez
voir le truc assez marrant en fait ça
c'est je pense que c'est une mission
donc ça c'est le iPhone et ils ont fait
vous allez voir le nombre d'iPhone
qu'ils ont récupéré qu'ils ont utilisé
pour faire ça c'est démentiel je pense
que très honnêtement ça leur a coûté une
petite fortune parce qu'il y a eu un peu
de casse ça a pas été évident regardez
le nombre là qui vous mettent il voyait
l'écran qui fonctionne pas donc ils ont
fini par réussir à extraire un écran
d'iPhone pliable qui peuvent venir plier
en tout cas qui est fonctionnel et qui a
pas de problème donc là ils utilisent un
Samsung Galaxy Z flip récupérer en fait
tout châssis pour mettre les composants
intérieurs parce que bien évidemment
l'idée pour que ce soit fonctionnel il
faut récupérer tous les composants de
l'iPhone et pour récupérer tous les
composants de l'iPhone il faut pouvoir
le mettre dans un châssis et avoir une
charnière fonctionnelle qui va venir
coller à leur écran parce que si vous
prenez l'écran de différents fabricants
de smartphone pliant et bien vous allez
voir que il y a une petite pliure qu'on
sent sous le doigt parce que l'écran je
pense est déjà un petit peu préplié pour
l'accompagner et éviter qu'il casse
comme ils ont récupéré si un écran d'un
iPhone x bien évidemment il est pas
préplié et si on va un peu trop loin on
risque de le péter donc il faut une
petite charnière qui permette d'accepter
que l'écran sont pas totalement plié
donc les charnières gouttes d'eau
typiquement qui sont un peu du bord à
bord on évite et la regarder la
charnière de Samsung et bien a priori il
y a un truc qui va pas le faire donc si
on avance de quelques secondes il
regarde la charnière il la sélectionne
pas vous allez voir que ils le prennent
et ils le test je voyais ils ont aussi
avec un écran dessus à eux je pense j'en
sais rien ça pique trop ça pince trop ça
abîme l'écran donc ce n'est pas
fonctionnel pour eux donc tout ce qui
est Samsung hop on met à la poubelle
ensuite ils sont venus chercher avec un
Motorola Razer et en fait ils vont
partir sur cette charnière là alors on
va pas se passer la vidéo on tient à
regarder comment ils font le truc mais
leur charnière a priori elle leur
convient davantage parce que vous voyez
elle pince moins a priori et vous allez
voir un peu plus loin c'est aussi
intéressant donc ils arrivent à venir
mettre leur écran sans que ça le plie
sans que ça le casse et ce qui leur
permet d'avoir un résultat qui
fonctionne donc ça c'est plutôt cool
ensuite bon on va passer un peu tout le
côté storytelling de leur vidéo allez
jeter un œil parce que bon les enfants
un peu des caisses mais ça reste très
efficace là on a effectivement l'iPhone
et à droite regardez là ils enlèvent les
différents éléments de l'iPhone qu'ils
ont récupéré et vous allez voir qu'en
fait il y a tous les composants les uns
après les autres et maintenant il y a un
vrai casse-tête un espèce de jeu de
puzzle qui va devoir se faire
reconstituer un iPhone mais on ne
pouvant pas le faire de cette manière là
c'est à dire que en fait sur tout le bas
ils sont venus mettre tout ce qui va
être carte mère tout ce qui va être
mémoire et sur le haut regardez la
batterie et le module photo que vous
avez là donc il faut forcément trouver
une architecture qui va être un peu
différente tout en sachant que eux à la
différence d'Apple s'ils le font s'ils
sont en train de travailler dessus ils
vont pouvoir retravailler un peu les
composants et les positions sur la carte
mère essayer ça eux c'est pas le cas
donc ils font déjà que de l'existence
qui est assez évident donc il faut
trouver un petit schéma interne c'est un
espèce de jeu de puzzle pour que tout
puisse fonctionner et une fois de plus
bien brancher l'écran sans que ça galère
et compagnie donc il faut peut-être bien
changer un peu des nappes il devenir
imprimer deux trois trucs alors moi je
pense de ce que je vois ce que je
comprends ce que tout ce qui va être
châssis tout est fait à l'imprimante 3D
sauf la charnière qui est son numéro sur
le châssis là vous allez le voir et vous
le verrez un peu plus tard que bon ils
vont polir ça avec Jean ça reste une
espèce de fraise et vous verrez qu'à la
fin voilà ça va forcément rendre un truc
qui va être un peu moyen donc tout se
fait ici à l'imprimante 3D on vient
ensuite trouver le bon emplacement et
vous allez voir donc là hop ce moment il
y a un peu marrant parce qu'en fait ils
ont même été jusqu'à mettre les petits
autocollants donc là il faut mettre
l'autocollant iPhone ici au niveau de la
charnière et ils vont vous mettre la
pomme au niveau du module photo alors
moi cette pomme j'aurais plus vu de
l'autre côté parce que quand il est
fermé et bien vous auriez cette espèce
de grande pomme en bas qui serait un peu
plus jolie que là bon une fois de plus
c'est un truc qui est fait pour se
marrer donc c'est pas un truc sérieux
c'est pas un produit de Apple une fois
de plus mais le rendu est là alors quand
je vous le disais tout à l'heure que ça
avait été je pense un peu poli avec une
fraise je sais pas comment on appelle ça
mais vous voyez là les irrégularités de
ce côté là même là là bon c'est vraiment
fait à l'arrache mais voilà une fois de
plus ils font comme ils peuvent est-ce
qu'ils ont fait déjà énorme vous le
voyez là le petit décroché la clac clac
mais malgré tout vous avez un vrai
iPhone et vous allez voir coffret iPhone
il est totalement fonctionnel what the
fuck je trouve ça fou quoi et regardez
donc là vous avez bien l'écran alors là
on le voit énormément vous voyez l'écran
comme il y a pas cette pré pliure qui
permet effectivement de devenir le
jointé complètement et bien ils ont un
espèce de jour qui est monstrueux et
quand il le PLIE vous allez voir vous
voyez quand il le PLIE tac voilà c'est
fermé cette charnière par rapport à ce
que eux ont fait c'est d'avoir cette
énorme jour qui ne vient pas plier
l'écran mais qui vient faire cette
courbe très prononcée qui reparle de
l'autre côté il est évident que s'il
Apple nous sort un iPhone qui se plie on
n'aura pas ça déjà Samsung se fait assez
critiquer sur le fait que comme ils ont
pas une charnière goutte d'eau et bien
on a un petit jour qui se dessine on
peut voir à travers au niveau de la
pliure avec le Galaxy Z flip mais on va
pas aussi loin globalement vraiment pas
donc bon il aille vous le montre ça
fonctionne alors la grosse limite du
truc si vous voulez c'est que comme on
est ici sur iOS qui est pas du tout fait
pour venir se plier c'est pas adapté
donc il y aura pas d'usage particulier
au fait qu'il se plie néanmoins il
fonctionne l'iPhone est totalement
fonctionnel plié droit de toute façon
l'écran il en sait rien si il est plié
il y a pas d'éléments qui lui permet de
le savoir mais il est fonctionnel donc
je trouve ça assez d'autres images la
photo bon la caméra fonctionne en fait
l'idée ici c'est de vous montrer que
tout fonctionne chez eux on peut mettre
du multitâche on se parle effectivement
ici d'un produit qui est totalement
fonctionnel ok c'est cool mais il est
évident que ce produit là c'est un petit
trip que c'est fait un défi je pense à
lancer un ingénieur chinois et c'est
très drôle parce que on voit quoi ça
peut ressembler sur iOS quand ça se plie
mais au-delà de ça c'est pas un truc qui
vient d'Apple ça veut pas dire que Apple
va réellement le sortir même si je pense
et ça me paraît logique que Apple
finisse par arriver dessus dès lors
qu'il y a un marché à moins que ça se
casse la gueule mais je pense pas parce
que franchement ça me saoule il met les
moyens et on voit même les pubs télé au
niveau des Samsung Galaxy Z flip c'est
évident pour moi il y a un marché et que
ça va continuer à fonctionner est-ce
qu'on va voir arriver un iPhone pliant
dans quelques années je pense très
honnêtement que oui quelle forme
aura-t-il je ne sais pas si on se base
sur ce qu'on a aujourd'hui le format
flip me paraît être le plus logique
est-ce que Apple va le faire oui au
moment opportun tout de suite c'est pas
encore opportun mais il est évident que
pour qu'il le sorte il doit travailler
dessus depuis très longtemps on
recherche un développement regardez
quand je vous ai parlé depuis très
longtemps de Samsung qui sortait ses
téléphones qui se plier sorti comment
ses promesses qui se plier c'était en
2019 fin 2018
2019 un truc comme ça je travaillais
quasiment 10 ans de peut-être 2011 on
trouvait les premières images les
premiers trucs le temps de concevoir une
charnière essayer ça alors même si
aujourd'hui l'industrie a évolué et même
si aujourd'hui Apple a forcément des
repères par rapport à ce que fait la
concurrence et qui a une vraie maîtrise
de la technologie là où Samsung a du je
pense venir la créer et bien pour autant
c'est pas évident de venir créer un
nouveau formator pour un produit alors
qu'il n'existe pas je parle bien ici
chez Apple même si son tracteur existe
ailleurs sur Android donc ça prendra du
temps de quelle manière est-ce qu'ils
veulent venir l'adresser j'en sais rien
ce qu'il teste différents formes factor
ça me paraît assez logique différent
type de produits différentes dimensions
différents usages allez savoir lequel il
croit réellement le plus en tout cas ça
va arriver c'est une certitude on sait
pas quand mais j'y crois énormément
d'ailleurs je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez vous est-ce que vous croyez que
l'iPhone pliant pliable finira par
arriver dites-le-moi dans les
commentaires et qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de ce truc là cette espèce d'OVNI
que nous a créé ce monsieur en Chine
est-ce que vous trouvez ça extrêmement
marrant dites-moi ce que vous en pensez
dans les commentaires si je vous
retrouve d'autres trucs un peu marrant
comme ça je vous les montrerai d'ici là
en faisant rendez-vous très bientôt
parce qu'il y aura plein de choses qui
arrivent et c'est très cool je vous
embrasse prenez soin de vous bisous Ciao
[Musique]